G
CROOKS AND POWERFUL UNLESS THEY
HAVE SOMETHING TO GAIN FROM IT
BEN SHAPIRO THE AUTHOR OF THE
AUTHORITARIAN MOMENT HOW THE
LEFT AUTHORIZED AGAINST THE --
BEN SHAPIRO JOINS US NOW.
I WISH I WAS SURPRISED BY WHAT I
SAW PLAY OUT IN FRONT OF US
TODAY.
AGAIN I LIVE IN THE GREAT
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA WHERE
WE STILL HAVE GOVERNOR RALPH
NORTHAM WHO LITERALLY EVERYONE
CALLED ON TO RESIGN AND STILL
THERE CAMPAIGNING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY -- CAMPAIGNING ACROSS
THE COUNTY TODAY FOR HIS WOULD
BE SUCCESSOR.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHAT
YOU SAW TODAY FROM LETITIA JAMES
AND YOUR THOUGHTS ON ANDREW
CUOMO?
>> GOVERNOR CUOMO CAME INTO
OFFICE TO GRAB AS AND KILL THE
ELDERLY HE IS ALL OUT OF THE
ELDERLY.
THE FACT THAT LETITIA JAMES LAID
THOUGHT CASE ABOUT SHOWER.
AND SEXUAL PRESSURE AND
RETALIATORY WORK ENVIRONMENT AND
ALL OF IT AND THEN SHE SAID AND
I'M NOT GOING TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT KIND OF TELLS YOU HOW
THIS IS ABOUT TO PLAY OUT.
YOU WILL RECALL AS YOU JUST
MENTIONED EVERYONE CALLED ON
RALPH NORTHAM TO RESIGN AND JOE
BIDEN CAMPAIGNING WITH RALPH
NORTHAM.
YOU EITHER DIE A HERO LIVE LONG
ENOUGH TO BECOME A VILLAIN OR
LIVE LONG ENOUGH TO CAMPAIGN AND
FUND RAISE.
>> Ben: ONE OF THE THINGS YOUR
BOOK TOUCHES ON IS THE DEMAND
PEOPLE HAVE IN THIS TIME TO HAVE
MORE AUTHORITY FROM GOVERNMENT.
EVEN AS THE FAITH IN
INSTITUTIONS DECAYS THERE IS
THIS ODD THING THAT HAPPENS
WHEREAS WE HAVE SEEN YOU KNOW,
HAPPEN IN MEXICO AND PLACES
AROUND THE WORLD WHERE MORE
AUTHORITY IS GIVEN TO THESE
FOLKS WHO HAVE ALREADY SHOWN
THEMSELVES COMPLETELY TERRIBLE
WHEN IT COMES TO USING IT.
YOU BELIEVE IN INSTANCE THAT
CUOMO IS JUST GOING TO HOLD ON
TO POWER AS HARD AS HE CAN AND
JUST KEEP FIGHTING BACK AGAINST
THIS, IGNORING WHAT BIDEN IS
SAYING, IGNORING WHAT OTHER
PARTY LEADERS ARE SAYING AND
JUST, YOU KNOW, TAKING A LESSON
THAT AS LONG AS YOU HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY YOU SHOULD NEVER GIVE
IT UP?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
NO ONE WANTS TO BE AL FRANKEN
AND LEFT OFFICE WHEN THEY COULD
HAVE JUST STAYED AND LIVED IT
THROUGH.
I ACTUALLY THINK WHAT YOU ARE
PROBABLY ABOUT TO SEE FROM
GOVERNOR CUOMO IS WAG THE MASK
SITUATION IN WHICH THE DELTA
VARIANT IS USED AS AN EXCUSE FOR
HIM TO PUSH NEW MEASURES THAT
ARE REALLY AUTHORITARIAN IN
NATURE AND THEN HE WILL BE
CHEERED BY THE PRESS AGAIN FOR
NOT BEING RON DESANTIS BECAUSE
THERE REALLY HAVE A DESIRE BY A
LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE ARE TO
BE CONTROLLED FROM ABOVE EVEN IF
THEIR LEADERS ARE CORRUPT AND
VENAL AND TERRIBLE THE WAY
GOVERNOR CUOMO IS ALL THIS
CONTROVERSY IS NOT HOW HE KILLED
HALF THE ELDERLY PEOPLE IN NEW
YORK.
THE DOJ ACTUALLY DROPPED ACTIVE
INVESTIGATION INTO HIS COVER-UP
OF THAT WE ARE JUST TALKING
ABOUT SOMETHING WE HAVE KNOWN
FOR A LONG TIME HE TREATS WOMEN
HORRIBLY.
THE FACT FOR CUOMO IF HE WISHES
TO WE GAIN ANY SENSE OF
POPULARITY AND CREDIBILITY.
MY GUESS IS THAT HE IS GOING TO
GO BIG AGAIN ONCE MORE ON COVID.
>> YOU KNOW HOW CORRUPT THE
MEDIA IS WHEN IT COMES TO
COVERING THESE TYPE OF
SITUATIONS OR POLITICIANS OF THE
IDEOLOGICAL VIEWS THAT THEY HAVE
OR CLOSE ENOUGH TO IT THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT PARTY LETTER AFTER
THEIR NAME.
I KNOW IN NORTHAM'S CASE AS SOON
AS IT BECAME APPARENT HE WASN'T
GOING TO BE REPLACED.
HE WASN'T GOING TO BE STANDING
DOWN THE MEDIA ESSENTIALLY WENT
SILENT AND PRETENDED THIS WASN'T
SOMETHING THEY NEEDED TO BE
ASKING ABOUT.
DO YOU EXPECT DEMOCRATS TO
ACTUALLY HAVE TO ANSWER FOR
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE WITH ANDREW
CUOMO IN THE COMING WEEKS OR DO
YOU BELIEVE SIMILARLY THE LAST
TIME AROUND CERTAINLY KNOWING
HIS CONNECTIONS OVER AT CNN THAT
HE IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO ESCAPE
THAT KIND OF MEDIA PRESSURE?
>>
>> NO IT WILL BE ONE NEWS CYCLE
AND GONE.
I WOULD EXPECT IT TO BE EXACTLY
THE SAME THING.
ALL WE HAVE TO DO TO FIGURE IT
OUT WATCH THE HUMAN WIND SOCK
KRISTIN GILLIBRAND AND SHE WILL
TELL US IN A COUPLE WEEKS
WHETHER IT HAS BLOWN OVER.
>> Ben: YOUR BOOK IS INTERESTING
AND TIMELY ONE IT SPEAKS TO ALL
THE THINGS WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT
IN THIS PANDEMIC.
THAT AMERICA IS GOING TO INVEST
EVEN MORE AUTHORITY IN OUR
GOVERNMENTAL LEADERS WHO HAVE
SHOWN THEMSELVES SO INCAPABLE OF
RISING TO THIS MOMENT AND SO
TERRIBLE AT ACTUALLY PUTTING
FORTH POLICIES THAT MADE THINGS
BETTER IN SO MANY INSTANCES.
WHAT CAN BE DONE TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST THIS ATHORN IMPULSE AS
WE SEE IT ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
WHAT CAN INDIVIDUALS DO IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND STATES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN?
>> WE REALLY DO NEED TO BAND
TOGETHER AT THIS POINT.
THERE IS NO QUESTION IF WE GET
TOGETHER TOGETHER WITH OUR AL
THRICE WE DO FORMULATE THE
MAJORITY.
I THINK THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
VERY HARD CORE MINORITY OF LEFT
WINGERS WHO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
COW PEOPLE INTO SILENCE AND MOVE
FORWARD INCREMENTALLY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT OF
PLIGHTNESS AND APATHY HAVE DONE
NOTHING.
THE BLOW BACK IS COMIN